[Music]
week two of the xfl 2020 season is in
the books and uh matt mcgloin had a
rough day and the access that they
provide included matt mcgloin
complaining about the offense at
halftime and i think it was benched in
the second half i mean look there's a
lot of things about the xfl tv
production that i like yeah and i hope
the nfl pilfers some of these aspects i
love the kickoff chris i know you've
watched no xfl no i got a great
alternative to the kickoff
where 10
players from each team are five yards
apart on the kickoff
yards away from the kick point they kick
off at the 30.
you kick off at your own 30. your 10
teammates are on the opposing 35 and
there are 10 other players from the
receiving team five yards away and they
all stand there frozen waiting for the
return man to catch the ball to reduce
the high impact collisions but the
problem is quarterback play and we saw
this coming you need star players you
need competent quarterbacks to make an
alternative football league work and
that's one of the reasons why we have
seen failure after fair after fair you
know people
and there's a loyal army of xfl fans for
some reason on social media and they
think any time that i post anything that
can remotely be construed is negative
that i'm getting paid by the nfl to say
bad things about the xfl no there's
plenty of bad things to say the football
is not anywhere close to nfl quality
because they don't have anything nearly
close to nfl quality quarterbacks the
closer they have is cardell jones who's
the only guy who had extended time in
the nfl and at one point was regarded as
maybe a potentially good nfl quarterback
he's been great for dc the other seven
quarterbacks even though landry jones
ended up with 305 passing yards
yesterday the only 300 yard passing
performance in the xfl this year landry
jones wasn't good either all of them
other than cardell jones have struggled
yeah i mean i'm not shocked i mean one
okay i haven't watched one second i
haven't i i i gotta say pj walker who
previously was philip walker right when
he was with the colts and never played
in a regular season game and andrew luck
raved to his father oliver luck the xfl
commissioner about pj walker he's been
good as well and his team is now
two-and-oh so it's not just cardell
jones cardell jones pj walker the other
six
yeah well i mean okay and you know i'm
gonna watch at some point because i want
to see you know the three-point play the
kickoff that you just mentioned i i
understand there's some cool wrinkles
out there i've had some friends tell me
that but i haven't watched a second and
i'm really not gonna watch much for the
reason you're talking about you know
screw the quarterback conversation
obviously that's not good enough the
whole league lacks star power you know
that's why we tune in to nfl football
because we want to see special and
they're special on every nfl roster same
thing for college football even though
there's a number of players that
wouldn't even be able to play in the xfl
or the nfl it doesn't matter we're still
seeing a star at some point and clemson
we're watching four or five stars that
are going to be in the nfl
yeah and they make a lot of good plays
because they're playing against some
guys that are never going to be in the
nfl not even a training camp so that
leads to explosive fun plays greatness
same thing with the nfl you know the
only league i have ever seen that's
gotten some juice and some leeway was
the usfl why
because it had star power
kelly reggie white steve young whatever
it may be it was a lot of really great
players that drummed up some interest i
don't want to watch a bunch of practice
squad nfl guys play real games against
each other i'm sorry i just don't want
to watch it
yeah and and i i just wonder whether or
not
the xfl would have broadcast deals with
espn and fox if they were trying to
actively attract nfl players away i
don't think the nfl would be happy about
it currently xfl isn't a threat to the
nfl but there are guys out there who
aren't the nfl that would make the xfl
better that johnny manziel they're not
interested in him well he's better than
some of the quarterbacks that are
playing in the xfl and he has star power
colin i think anyone is he went up to
canada and didn't look good let's find
out okay colin kaepernick's available
hey and the other thing that they
apparently aren't inclined to do they
aren't inclined to go after college
players who aren't yet eligible for the
draft if trevor lawrence were playing in
the xfl and getting five to ten million
dollars this year and next year before
he's eligible to enter the draft i mean
it would help the xfl and it'd be hard
for him to say no because it's five to
ten million more per year than he's
currently getting at clemson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports